ابرز نتائج الدراسه التي قيمت نظام اربعه
ايام عمل وثلاثه ايام اجازه في الشارقه
زياده انتاجات الموظفين بنسبه
88% وواحد التواصل الايجابي بين الموظفين
وابرزت الدراسه ايضا ان الالتزام بالحضور
ارتفع بنسبه 74% هو انخفضت لاجزات المرضيه
بنسبه 46% واوضحت الدراسه ان معدل الرضا
الوظيفي والاداء الوظيفي ارتفع بنسبه 90%
وارتفع بنسبه 91% الشعور بالسعاده بشكل
عام وبنسبه 87% التاثير الايجابي في الصحه
النفسيه وفق الدراسه فان نظام يحقق بنسبه
84% التوازن بين الحياه العمليه والاسريه
و96 زياده في الاستمتاع بالعطله الاسبوعيه
70% زياده نسبه المشاركه في المناسبات
الاجتماعيه واثنين بالمئه زادت الفرصه في
ممارسه الرياضه والهوايات الخاصه
وفيما يخص مستوى متعامل الجهات الحكوميه
اوضحت الدراسه شعور المتعاملين بمعدل رضا
عال عن جوده الخدمات واداء الموظفين بشكل
عام بنسبه 94%